je suis pas inquiet d'un problème de
qualité des compétences je pense qu'on a
on a des compétences de qualité on a un
problème de quantité et le problème de
quantité il est lié au fait que la
filière n'a pas construit depuis
longtemps en tout cas la construite de
façon industrielle depuis longtemps il
est lié aussi que notre pays c'est un
petit peu
contracté sur les métiers techniques en
général
et que et c'est à échelle du pays c'est
pas la chaîne d'une filière et puis il
est lié au fait que
temporairement aujourd'hui à cause de la
corrosion contrainte mais demain parce
que nous devrons cumuler à la fois de la
construction neuve et des travaux qui en
fait sont aussi compliqués que de la
construction neuve sur la maintenance du
parc en réalité nos besoins numériques
nos besoins quantitatifs
vont vraiment croître massivement par
rapport à ce que nous avons connu même à
l'époque de la construction neuve du
premier parc donc ce dont nous parlons
c'est un effet démographique sur les
tous les métiers techniques et ils sont
tous égales importants
qui est lié en fait à la conjonction de
ces phénomènes pour probablement les
deux décennies qui nous attendent donc
il faut prendre ça comme comme un plan
industriel et c'est comme ça que nous le
prenons donc ça a commencé déjà depuis
plusieurs années maintenant il faut pas
passer la surmultiplier donc nous allons
continuer de prendre des initiatives
donc vous avez parlé des écoles des
métiers de deux métiers qui est un qui
est un concept auquel je crois mais il y
en a d'autres donc je pense qu'il je
sais bien je sais bien donc je donc
c'est un concept auquel je crois et donc
je suis en train de travailler dessus
mais pas seulement c'est à dire qu'il
faut vraiment qu'on regarde la totalité
des compétences et enfin voilà on est un
grand pays mais on n'est pas non plus
une population
infinie donc lorsque EDF continue de
faire des projet à l'étranger c'est
aussi pour avoir un bassin d'emploi qui
ne soit pas limité à la France parce que
le bassin d'emploi de la France n'est
pas suffisant en réalité pour engendrer
tous les besoins de la filière en tout
cas au moment de pic parce que là aussi
c'est pas c'est pas un plateau uniforme
sur 20 ans nous allons avoir des moments
dans lesquels on a besoin de tout le
monde et le phénomène de la corrosion
sous contrainte exactement celui-ci en
une période très limitée on a besoin de
toutes les compétences possibles et
c'est quand toutes ces compétences
possibles elles dépassent le chant
français